[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soir les enfants
bonsoir
[Musique]
bonsoir 2
ouvert aujourd'hui nous étions bien loin
nous a t-on
droit de rentrer de croître
avez-vous bien joué un début bien
chanter avez-vous j'étais gentil et ça
je crois que quelques enfants ont été
depuis ton et chant au bâton mais nous
étions en voyant
10 koldo rentrons chez nous pas
non officiels
les garçons
je connais janine tischer une itw en
hausse et est trop gentil
essaye de nous verrons oui mais à
condition qu'ils aient une conduite de
parfaits
patron vous serez surpris moi je vous le
garantis alors nous nous arrive à tue
tête
bonsoir les enfants on est bien content
aujourd'hui pour qu'a longtemps
hop on
tous les soirs
dire aux noceurs
elisany
bonne nuit à petit sa vie
et maintenant je descend vite retrouvé
mes petits tapis
bon le seul mais ne traîne pas trop
nounours un simple aller-retour pas trop
et hop hop hop hop hop hop hop robot
chicken t'attendais dévoilait des fleurs
avec notre coeur
mais ce merveilleux merci le en je suis
si content d'être revenu au jeu qu'on
attendait d'abord avait voulu tessa
alors voilà des bonbons pour toi
patronne elle est pour toi
nicolas merci c'est gentil nounours moi
j'aime tellement les bonbons et cela ils
sont bons ils sont au miel
c'est ma soeur emilie à qui veut les
envoyer l ordre à rien et les gentils
caceres jeux wii patron
j'arrive à lons les enfants au dodo
sinon je vais me faire gronder
voilà le nom on vous dira tu vois comme
on et ça gêne on s'est fait plaisir et
c'est bien demain je viendrai jouer avec
vous très loto c'est promis
promise reproduit à l' ademe anah neuf
sauf toi vite là je tends la lumière un
demain a dit nicolas pimprenelle bonsoir
mes enfants gentils nous sommes bien
contents de vous retrouver endormi vous
vite et faites de beaux rêves
à demain bolbec
oh
[Musique]